wir sind gerade am flughafen angekommen
wir haben jetzt allerdings noch vier
stunden zeit bis unser flug geht
und deswegen haben wachsen dich uns
gedacht dass wir einfach jetzt für die
34 stunden nach manchester fan einfach
mal schauen was man so ein 34 statt wie
viel zeit haben auch wir schauen jetzt
mal was man alles in keine ahnung wie
vielen stunden manchester machen kann
wir haben jetzt gerade unsere tipps
geholt für den zug wir wissen zwar nicht
wann der abwertung wurde abwehrt aber
wie kommt schon irgendwie wollen
die kirche möchte uns dass wir hier
nicht fehlen dürfen
wir machen das trotzdem wir sind
manchester bahnhof angekommen und gehen
jetzt in die stadt hier sind jetzt seit
einer stunde manchester gelesen was ich
bisher geschafft habe ist mein video
hochgeladen
das war's eigentlich jedenfalls haben
wir jetzt gerade noch sonst social
experience mehr oder weniger gedreht und
sind wir zum verein angehört deutsche
wetter vorlesen das jetzt glaube ich
schon auf meinem kind nicht was ich noch
sagen wollte das video ist
wahrscheinlich schon auf einem kanal
online
wir haben halt grad gedreht mehr konnte
ich nicht machen
wir dachten kehrten drei bis vier
stunden da dann hätten wir viel mehr
fällen können aber unser flieger geht
gleich ganz geschlossen flieger
weil du so genau aber ich denke schon
wir sind jetzt so dass manchester wieder
zurück am flughafen und laufen jetzt
über diesen tollen treppe
zu unserem geld
ob
wer bin ich vielleicht die werte dame
von der kontrolle junge dame nicht
wirklich einig hätte sprengstoff meiner
kamera drin nano phase tuch genommen
komisch mit lukas laptop und kamera so
abgewischt oben genommen hat es denn so
eine maschine reingelegt so richtig
crazy jetzt endlich öffentlich angeblich
für den flieger
und wie